so what's up y'all welcome to riffin
with Griffin I don't know if this is
episode 2 or 3 I can't really tell I'm
just I'm still trying things out I just
want to talk about the NBA season NBA
season has been fantastic I'm a Clippers
fan I got season tickets with Adam I
know hey don't hate it is what it is and
we so we got season tickets and I'm just
really liking what the Clippers are
doing right now I'm actually loving the
whole NBA season if I'm being real with
everybody you know that I even
subscribed to the NBA app where's the
NBA yeah yeah I got the NBA app going
you know there's just a lot of good
things my Clippers look Doc Rivers they
took away being head of basketball
operations from him he's just the coach
now they brought in Jerry West the logo
as a consultant and I think it's paying
dividends right now I mean the team is
playing good I mean I can't hate on the
Clippers man you know they got Patrick
Beverley back he's the heart and soul of
defense but they got a bunch of great
guards I'm just looking at it so I can
get him all right cuz they got Patrick
Beverley he's a main player Avery
Bradley and then Shai Gil just Alexander
that dude's name is so big it's touching
both buttcheeks on his jersey but I love
him I love marcin Gortat
I love montrezl harrell he always dunks
every time he gets the ball then we got
Tobias he's our superstar well he's our
star really and then Bob on Bob on 7-4
he got that gigantism disease or
whatever it is but he's taking full
advantage just like Andrei the dying did
we got my bootays back from Houston
after he left and came back Melo's is
still here he's playing good um what
else we got here of course Lou Williams
score 15 on goal to stay last year and
then we just got a bunch of like scrappy
players and everybody comes in and plays
hard
how I know the team is pretty good or
above-average let's say is when you look
on NBA Live or NBA 2k and you look at
the Clippers stats they're all like 77
78 79
there's nobody just like a 60 or 65 of
the main players that play there all
right around there 77 to like 85 rating
on the basketball games and I think
that's pretty good
so they always play hard excuse me I've
been to like a few the home games
already cuz I wasn't out of town and
we've just you know we've played good we
beat Houston twice already if you don't
have a full squad you don't have your
stars my Clippers are gonna beat you
period so you got to come with it
now they played they're gonna be playing
going to stay pretty soon they don't
play Minnesota they playing all the good
teams in the West and I think we holding
our own are we gonna win the
championship no you know I mean it would
be foolish to think the Clippers are
going to championship but we're a tough
out you can't just come to LA and think
you're gonna win I'm just telling you
that right now so I'm really liking what
like I said we like what the Clippers
are doing I think it's fun you know when
you're really a fan of a sports team
like what does that really mean it's
something about it like a lot of times
it has to do with family like did you go
to the games with your father
like every time you every time you have
some kind of like personal connection to
to the sport did you play this board you
know it's not even just about the city
you came from there's always some kind
of story out for me the Clippers see I
was born and raised in LA and I used to
work at this grammar school and there
was a kid that he was like he was my the
quarterback on my football team a flag
football team he was like he played
basketball he was just like that kid he
was charismatic he was you know he you
know he's a ladies man his name was
Danny I'll never forget Danny he and his
mom worked at Stadium at the Sports
Arena at the time and she was like she
was like worked in concessions but you
know they had a tough time selling
tickets so they would kick two tickets
down to the people that worked there too
so she
get tickets so one day we're just we're
he just random he says hey coach you
want to go to the clipper game and I was
like what what do you mean and he was
like yeah well my mom works at the
stadium we can get tickets so she gave
me these tickets and I'm sitting here at
the game and I'm like you just telling
me about these tickets now he was that
kind of kid he just you know whatever
you know you know I'm not a lot of
people knew so then he would just get me
tickets to the game and then that's how
I started to become a clipper fan well
first uh you don't go you're not a
clipper fan you know you go to the
clipper games back in the day to watch
the other teams and at the time I love
to watch Shawn Kemp and Gary Payton at
Seattle SuperSonics
oh man Ellis those are the days man
those games with a [__] so you would
like support the team you went to go
watch against the Clippers he would go
watch them he would support that team
for like four quarter three and a half
quarters and then you would be like okay
now we got a switch to the home team
because you know it's the Clipper home
game and then it just turned into
something you know Terry to hair and Ken
Norman and Mark Jackson was playing back
then and they did they just got a Larry
Brown they brown started coaching you
know they had a nice little run and you
know they got to the playoffs they lost
in the first round of Houston in five
games I got to go to those playoff games
and but I was close because of you know
and I just remember my personal story is
I love the Clippers it's because of his
kid you know he you know Danny was you
know I usually I'm talking about is cuz
he tragically died he was you know in a
go-kart
you know he's that kind of kid
adventurous and so he had just go-kart
in the street and he got hit by a car
and he slipped into a coma and he he
never got out of it and you know that
was just it was sad you know like when a
kid dies you really feel that and they
touch more lives I'm now remember you
know it was a Catholic school grammar
school and you know they were having a
funeral and they had the auditorium was
full and the church was full of people
and they asked me to do his eulogy and
that was tough and I've talked about
this story before and other podcasts and
whatnot but business for me as my own
podcast
and you know so I read so they gave me a
thing you had to read about him
so like I read you know this stuff about
him and I told myself I wasn't gonna cry
I was like don't cry cuz there's a lot
of people watching they had cameras so
the people in the auditorium can see
what was going on and I'm just chill not
even listening to the priest because
they told me two priests would call me
up I'm not listening to what's going on
and I'm thinking I'm okay and then they
play Ave Maria
man Niagara Falls like I was just done
so then I go up you know I read the
little thing you know he's survived by
his mom it's grandma
his great-grandma you know he was Latino
so she was like 40 and just kidding like
there's nobody here to laugh but that
would have been a nice well whatever I
gotta remember that I'm not doing
stand-up but anyway I go this is my
nature this is also the first time I
realized I really wanted to be a
stand-up it was like so I'm on here time
and then I start talking about him
and I started to talk about well he's
probably causing havoc in heaven and I'm
noticing a bunch of his girlfriends are
here and you know he's gonna get in
trouble and as I started talking people
started to laugh people started to be
like remembering him in that way and
that was that there and I was like damn
I'm killing it this funeral that's when
I was like I should man I need to be a
comedian you know that was one of the
first times I decided that but anyway to
get back on track is I think part of the
reason why I love the Clippers and it's
just in remembrance of him too and like
in and that's what sports is you know
playing catch with your dad or whatever
it is that you know going to the stadium
it's something special about it
you know routine and that's for me as
long as the team is like playing hard
and and they're entertaining and they're
out there actually you think they're
trying to win like that's important
they're out there trying to win if
that's happening then damn I'm all for
it and the Clippers a plane like that
right now but just to talk about the NBA
in general of course everybody is all up
and everybody's all like oh la is bad
cuz LeBron James
LeBron James is a here in LA but I've
never been really a Laker fan I was a
Kobe hater I'm a proud Kobe hater I
respect the game but I just did not like
Kobe Bryant sorry you know what I mean I
think he should have went to college I
think he would have learned how to be a
better teammate if he had had that
experience I don't think he would have
threw Shaq under the bus I think they
would have got together and stayed
together but if he went to college he
probably never would have played with
Shaq so who knows what would have
happened but I just think it would have
helped him be like a better team player
if he went to college I think an
experience that he was as far as whole
life so we needed and he was always in
charge in a way you know so I don't know
I just wasn't a Laker fan always support
the Clippers but anyway you got LeBron
James now in LA and they're not doing
that good what's their record right now
and you look at my MBA app so we sitting
here let me see what's that record I
don't even know what the standings all
this girl of standings I love looking at
the standings right now so currently the
standings as of right now
Milwaukee's at the top of the East seven
and one oh that means they lost Golden
State obviously a 1 you got Denver 7 & 1
hey we played Denver opening game we
played we should have won that game but
Denver's obviously looking good
Portland is 6 & 2 Portland's good they
still got that little dude Damian
Lillard but I just don't I think he's
too small I don't think he's gonna be
able to do anything in the playoffs I
don't think he's ever gonna be able to
do anything into the plows until they
get some other dudes around him that
like bigger lengthier but he could use a
stefan curry thing but you have to have
a better team around him
San Antonio five and two tomorrow's and
good for you brother good for you making
that move and you're making the impact
check out Sacramento as six and three
that's the one that gets me Darren
Darren Fox or Fox whatever his name is
he had a triple-double just recently
Memphis still good foreign to Utah check
our Utah four and three and New Orleans
falling for thought they were gonna be
better and there's my Clippers at number
nine at four and four I mean just that
Western Conference is just like look at
it you still got Houston Dallas Lakers
Oklahoma sea
in Minnesota behind my clippers that's
how crazy the Western Conference is so I
look forward to seeing where that ends
and in the east you got Milwaukee
Toronto Boston Indiana Detroit Philly at
six
Charlotte Miami I mean damn excuse me if
you're a basketball fan at all you got
to love what's going on this season it's
just it's just a lot of great stuff
going on this season I'm I'm really I'm
really excited about the NBA and then
some of the things that happen is like
like I wanted to talk about that Rondo
and the Lakers Houston squabble you know
when you look at it it just it looks I
mean did the kid Ingram he started the
whole thing by just not keeping his
composure and you know pushing what's
his name then it just escalated from
there but like did Rondo spit in his
face I mean when they slowed it down and
ate zoom the camera zoom into the little
area it did look like he purposely spit
on them you know and that's it's just
one of those spits that you you can't
really omit it you don't have to admit
it you could be like it was an accident
he had a mouthpiece in and then you know
he got mushed you know Chris Paul was
like don't spit in my face at me but
then [__] Juan don't clocked him good
that's like a fool no problem so that
was um that was crazy that's how and
then we just that's we were talking
about it for like a week out or two
weeks after we still look at me I'm
still talking about it so they just I
can't wait for them to play again it's
just the excitement of the league it's
great so I'd suggest you watch the NBA I
don't know if you guys are NBA fans what
your team is but you know try to support
and I do suggest you go watch a game you
know I remember um well Jordan retired I
never saw Jordan play and then and then
he came back and then he was with the
Wizards and then I went to the Clipper
game and watched Jordan play with the
Wizards and it just wasn't the same but
he still was electric LeBron James is
like that LeBron James got that way when
you watch LeBron you like something's
going on in the stadium it's weird
certain players are like de he's one of
them magic was like that knows magic
bird probably I'd never saw bird play
live um he just Jordan had that thing
and I just regretted not going to see
Jordan and I'm telling you all to like
you know what you should do you got to
go see stuff live I mean it really
changes it just gives you like it's such
a euphoric feeling it's such like
you know you you feel like you're a part
of something I suggest you go see your
favorite comedians go see your favorite
music artist go to a concert man those
things stay with you forever like I
remember I watched my first concert I
went to was Michael Jackson victory tour
it was at the Dodger Stadium
I'll never forget that I was a huge
Michael Jackson fan I went with my
cousin and we were so excited oh my god
it was so sunny and then it just you
know that was like the time Motown 25
all that stuff was going on the moonwalk
and he was at the height of his power
and I was always like whoa I saw Michael
Jackson live like during that time that
he was like the King of Pop so I think
you should do that I mean I've had like
I saw Madonna
I just recently the last few years I've
seen Madonna a couple times but she's
great
Madonna is always great but I wish I'd
seen like Madonna like 32 year old
Madonna like when she was just you know
but you know not not to say that 60 year
old Madonna is it's just not the same I
mean it's just the songs aren't new
you know like look how would have been
to go watch like you know like a virgin
when it was like still on a radio or you
know you just it was like you're oh my
god a Material Girl or Papa don't preach
and all those songs as they came out you
know with in conjunction with going to
see the concert I think that would have
made it like a lot better so I just like
I say go see no matter how small the
venue is you know if you if you're like
whatever the little band you like you
gotta go watch them live and it just it
changes it man
it really feels good so I say that about
sports to they go to a football game go
to a basketball game go to a bass book I
don't even like baseball but when you go
to a baseball game it is like
there you get hot dogs you're talking
with people you just feel the energy
then you know when you get bored they
play this song into seventh innings and
you know the haste time to pay attention
because the games going on all that kind
of stuff is fun man I'm telling you you
got to get out there and watched it and
you gotta go see comedians go see you
can't trust what happens on TV take it
from me you know I did two specials now
and I don't you know I don't know if
they're good or not actually I'm proud
of my specials that I did but like did
that capture that energy that I have
when I'm at the club it's so I can't
explain it but like a live unfiltered
experience you gotta go see that you
gotta go see it so I'm telling you go
out buy some tickets and go watch your
favorite comedians go watch your
favorite artists go watch your favorite
sports teams and even you know you can
say all you want about the Clippers
excuse me but when you go to the game
and you're sitting there you feel
something hockey - oh that's the one you
really got to go watch - I've been to a
couple of Kings games and like I don't
always understand what's going on with
hockey but when you out there watching
it man Oh something special out there
y'all something special so yeah man
that's really all I want to talk about
right now you know this riffing with
Griffin and you know sometimes it just
come on for a quickie you know I'm not
all corporate yet I don't got sponsors
and all that I'm looking for it but it's
just right now this is just me giving
you my thoughts and ideas I'm just out
here riffing I got some interview set up
but for the first five to ten it's just
gonna be me you got you have something
you want me to talk about you have any
questions or anything like that
you're becoming a fan and you want to
hear me talk about something you know
hey send me a direct message hit me up
on the YouTube comments and I will be
more than happy to do that and you know
I'll talk about the NBA all year long
because a lot of stuff going on the NBA
think my next episode though is gonna be
about these dating shows I've been
watching I mean I've been watching
90-day fiance gotta talk about this
this show if Yuri aids me but you'll
hear about that one next but anyways
this aircraft and this is riffing with
Griffin thank you for listening I love
you